Hi there
and thank you for joining us for our first panel
discussion on the innovations of in
healthcare in emerging economies. We
doing this together with Science Mission LLC
in the US.  First off I'd like to
begin by introducing a little bit about
Heroes of STEM
essentially we're a community of professionals
from science technology engineering and
tech backgrounds and we're looking to
address three key objectives the first
being improving Inter-disciplinary
communication and collaborations. The
second is to improve access and
visibility of stem ventures initiatives
and also individuals with the intent
build mentor-mentee associations across
different geographies and also to improve the
provision and support of skill
based training of people who maybe are
from less privileged or less
accomplished backgrounds. The final
objective we're trying to achieve is start
discussions about universally accepted
and important challenges particular such
as healthcare which is why we're having
this discussion today in order to start
creating more of a frame work and proposal change
and all this aligns with our motto
which is Purposeful impact
So withthat information at hand
I'd like to begin by introducing a panel
we have to begin with Dr. Kaustubh Dhargalkar
from Mumbai who is someone with
multiple hats. He has been in the past
an entrepreneur consultant and academic
and currently active mentor at a center
for innovation at the Indian Institute
of Management in Ahemdabad.
Besides this of course Kaustubh is a
contributing writer to Knowledged@
Wharton. He is also an academic who has a
mental number of health care startups in
an India in particular, and his spare time
I believe he practices and teaches yoga as well
Is that right Kaustubh?
yeah yeah thanks thanks for the
introduction. Thanks for joining us. We have
Dr Sudha Rao who I've had the
pleasure meeting
quite recently as well who has the
incredible foresight expertise that we
really need india from the genomics
background multiomics background
even. She is co-founder & executive director of
genomic genotypic technologies in
bangalore and currently also a founder
at Dhitiomics which is diagnostically
oriented if there's something you'd like
to add that Sudha please feel welcome to
Yes I think even that we were perhaps
one of the first companies in india i'm
almost unheard of space so Dhiti endeavours
to bring in cutting-edge genome sequencing
to clinical diagnostics. We'll speak about it more through
progress discussions.
We're very excited to have your views on this
discussions as well.
Finally we have Dr. Nick Seneca
from Zurich in Switzerland.
Nick I've also known during this time at
as a director and head of Astrazeneca
translational Science Group where he worked
closely together the Karolinska
Institute and he has a lot of expertise
in the strategy and the product design
and planning when it comes to
pharmaceuticals and essentially
his experience through Roche and
Astrazeneca he has insights coming from more
the Giants from the industry that nature
Currently Nick is the director and
chief scientist at PMOD technology and
the focus there is medical imaging and
neural imaging. Something you'd like to add to that Nick?
Thank you very much for the
introductions look forward to
contributing to this. Thank you very much and i
am Dr. Kirti Kaul. I'm essentially
molecular biologist expertise in
diabetes & diabetic complications and it is
an absolute honor and privilege to be
able to have a discussion of these three
of experts and panelists. So I'd
like to begin with a very basic question
first off there
Dr. DHargalkar. I should also point out
that we have the possibility of
addressing questions towards the end of
the session. So please will feel welcome
to either include them as comments or
in the IM. This is for the viewers and
Dr. Dhargalkar if you could just begin
by telling this and what is your
understanding how would you go about
defining an emerging economy so we can
really start for the  benefit of viewers who don't
necessarily understand economy side of it
as much. Emerging economies is the term
itself are growing economies somewhere
in that middle phase between a undeveloped
economy and stable economy
typically characterized by low
industrial penetration more regrerian
kind of an economy. Lower per capita
incomes a little lower education levels
lower penetration of banking services
but growing fast
the rate of growth of GDP being higher than
the stable economies obviously because
the base is smaller for the gdp
calculation. These economy is kind of
leapfrogging the development
trajectory which developed economies
have gone through a couple of very
cliche examples would be how India
jump over the landline telephones straight in the
mobile phone also you know in that we don't
have a brick-and-mortar banks in India
but people do mobile banking so that's
the kind of digitization that is
happening and which is taking these
emerging economies faster in the growth
trajectory that's how I would define as
maybe typically between you know three
to seven percent gdp growth
would be the typical definition of an
emerging economy in this context
This actually brings us to the idea why is
it relevant to
talk about healthcare innovations in emerging
economies and I think this is again
something that be we briefly touched on
together and the notion that emerging
economies could just be following the
exact same model as an existing
developed country is already
implementing what do you think might be
an argument against why do we need
innovation in healthcare systems and
possibly model in emerging countries. You
want me to take it? If you can I want to
or anybody else wants to take
actually I think we're just trying to build
the grounds for the relevance as to why is it
important to actually have this discussion
why we're looking to change and or even
discuss changes, and possible changes
in healthcare models
in emerging economies. Now one
example of this or one way of looking at it
is usually through the eyes of someone like
Prof Govindrajan who mentions that
emerging economies are like mega markets
with microconsumers where traditionally
stable economies you might have one
individual one consumer with the capacity to spend
10 US dollars, in emerging economies you
actually have 10 users with the capacity of one dollar
Which has it's own challenges but also it has
some creativity and we're a very
different format and very different dynamic and
this is something we will appreciate through
comments of Kaustubh and Nick from the
more industrial broad setting and from
Sudha from the technological expertise
settings. I think from from the
actual structure of...we should be...
what our immediate goal should be...
first-person if i might ask Sudha in
your opinion what's the most important for
promising area either in terms of technology
or modeling systems which can pose itself
as an innovation in healthcare relevant to
emerging countries. So I build this on
context of india coming from. We're about
1/6 th the global population
if you see the spend on healthcare its paritry
compared to even for example Brazil spends more
on health than us and we have
considerable challenges and we don't
have formal systems we don't have good
regulatory system and not activate
insurance board so much of innovation
has happened from the private sector and
the implementation and its governance to
government agencies if you look at
some infectious diseases classic example use
ofcourse one is that we already proud
that we eliminated polio as a country
and larger challenges like tuberculosis
big burden on the country, countless cases
and the challenge there is to health
care centers and good diagnostics. So
couple of years ago I think the government
implemented system called gene expert in
every district hospital in the country
what we realize now is that that's not
enough so access is still an issue and
what that has spurred is a lot of
innovation in the point of care diagnostic where
you need little investment of
technologies your small quick analyze
and not you know capital-intensive and
that's a lot of innovation is happening
and from genetic diagnostic perspective
again we are very diverse ethnic population
right we have so many ethnicities
there are no efforts to establish a
baseline for genomic data that gives
us enormous opportunity to understand
it better and personalized treatments
and that's an effort a few companies
even started and Dhiti is one of them and so
what this
understanding the is can we use is now
predictive healthcare because I did read
about the changing demographics 20 years
down the line south of India we have
because the growth rate has declined
adults we have an aging population the earning
population being less. Two states in the
north that will have younger population that is
unemployed so the burden on health care
will be high and you need to be prepared
and I think predictive test will be important
yes that's a lot better
here was trying to say is we believe that
genotyping might be the future when it comes to healthcare in emerging economies
i'm afraid I cannot get your question
Is that addressed to me or to Kaustubh?that was
you right there they are that area
genotyping will be very important i think for a country like India
Genotyping will be very
important diagnostic foregoing
population and I think Nick here
will share, AstraZeneca has I think
initiated the largest sequencing effort
in the world a million of them Nick? I forget
the actual number which goes to show
the importance of understanding
the genetic variations in the human population to
aid better diagnostics more specific so
it is going to be definitely the future
for a populous country like ours but
really practical insight there
Let's ask Kaustubh
What is the most promising area
promising areas of innovation in order to improve healthcare
just taking off what Sudha mentioned
remote diagnostics
centers for remote diagnostics
Levels are still lower. What I see coming is
lot of future for you know cheap
wearable devices which would be probably
operated on the like a franchisee level
where a locally trained youth or anybody from
a village or somebody operates those
wearable devices and people come to those
kiosks and all that data is captured. if i
can share screen i would like to show
one you know one particular device like
this which came out of MIT media lab but
inspired in India. Absolutely
Please go ahead please. Can you see that?
we don't have your screen so far no
not yet...sharing the screen and desktop
can you see it now? I'm afraid not yet
Kaustubh ah it's it's called i-netra
maybe people can google it up it's a
simple plastic box like thing and you
can attach a smartphone with an i-netra app
and it becomes diagnostic tool for
you know checking out to...for an
opthamologist typically colorblindness
know the power of the specs etc now
that's a device which costs probably
something like
fifty or sixty dollars that's it and
this is the kind of thing that you know
a connected India might be able to
capture all this data and can be
linked with the Adhaar card the uid
unique identification authority of India
all that data can be
captured on these kinds of platforms
and that's where the government can
really really use it very effectively can
make this data available for private
companies to to to really take the
execution piece because the government
can't really get into execution at all
levels but it would definitely create
the platform UID is being
talked about for as a financial
technology financial Fintech innovation
but the way the government of india is
going about UID i think a lot more
can be tapped and that's where the data
that Sudha's also talking about the
other really powerful tool. that's what I
see coming up in future. Fantastic
that's actually very fair point
you're talking in terms of the power of
big data in some ways we're just having
multiple data points in order to further get into precision
medicine as was also the comment from Sudha
unfortunately we've lost nick shortly
here at whose common would also be I
think we can come back to perhaps in the
meantime in the interest of time we can
move on to the second question which is
to do with the we understand of course a
lot of novel use of diagnosis as also
you just recently mentioned cause the
growing number of new diagnostic
strategies these days ranging from your
home
genetic testing kits to
apps medically oriented apps and a lot
of it is down to just data acquisition
and data crunching but that as a
counter-argument what we often find with
countries like India China Brazil which
are often knowledge-based there's a
certain degree of skepticism when it
comes to data sharing as well in your
mind while on the other hand of course
there's a lot of openness to the digital
media so as you rightly we're also
pointing out... everything is... if things are
in an app for more likely to be taken up
by the consumer in your mind what do you
think are the chances of novel
diagnostics or these disruptive
technologies in a sense to make it big
in countries like India if I might start
this please with the actually Nick
in this instance if that's ok so how to implement them you
mean or can I answer the one question
about opinion of what are then promising
technologies gonna start with that then
we don't have a potentially
implementation but yeah so if I can just
to build on what the others have already
said yeah I think yeah wearables are
definitely a good potential way forward
especially have seen that at Roche where
they especially in movement disorders
have looked at wearables and parkinson's
disease as you know a lot of the
endpoints in clinical trials are kind of
movement related or patient oriented
type of outcome measures so whatever
pharma companies can do or whatever
physicians can do to track patients so
any type of voice movement balance all
these types of things which could be
tracked just via an app on your
mobile phone I mean this is really
important especially in the area of
multiple sclerosis and parkinson's
disease were looking at changes in
movement is really important i think
Sudha already alluded to the large
genomics you know support from
astrazeneca now is for Ruth March
did a great job getting that approved
and it's going to be a very big
collaboration I think for emerging
markets and even its kind of medicine in
hard-to-reach places is very hard to get
biopsies of patients and Roche and
Astrazeneca had done a very good job on
getting circulating tumor DNA by also
like a liquid biopsies so anyway to
confirm a diagnosis and something other
than a biopsy that's a little bit easier
to get from a
patient of course is a quite a really
good advancement in the treatment of
patients and of course it's not only
about the circulating tumor DNA it's
also ensuring that the patient has the
right mutation because we don't want to
be treating patients that don't respond
with a drugs that won't help them at all
so in terms of any if you think about
what types of things we need to be able
to diagnose the patient the biopsy is
quite challenging the
pathology itself is not always one
hundred percent so anything we can do to
kind of simplify things so simplifying a
biopsy from a blood sample for a liquid
biopsy I think companies like Astra and
others are doing quite a good job on
this if we think about other areas of
Technology Innovation I mean I'm not one
hundred percent sold on this but
companies like luminosity they've done
quite a good job of trying to track how
good memory training is so they offer
and a App to look at memory training
whether or not this really helps
cognitive function long term I think
that's unknown but in terms of
innovation technology potential areas
this is something anyone can can use on
a daily basis
um I think wearables are are good i
still unfortunately think they're at
least my personal feelings are a bit of
a fad and I think you can take wearables
and do one way better
I mean many companies already tried this
or are trying it and you take wearables
and make it a little bit better to
ingestables so i think we will
see a big push and smart pills and
sensors and transmitters that people
digest I really think this is the way
forward I mean wearables are great i think that
will help build the pathway for
ingestible I really think this could be
a potential way forward
of course these could be a bit more
expensive but if you bring down the
production costs that could be more
distributed more widely so that as
you're were rightly pointing out that is
down to a need once the market arises course
there will be more of an impetus on bringing
down costs i think what both Sudha
and  Kaustubh were trying to allude to is the fact of just
having a multiplicity of data multiomics
if you will. Not just
wearable necessarily but also any other
form of technology that does give you
access to multiple bits of data in real
time from the same individual in order to devise
an outcome or diagnostic. So I think we seem
to be on similar opinion from
all our three panelists in this case but
I think also already briefly address the
way you seen or Diagnostics heading in
some ways through these ingestables
perhaps we can now have a Sudha take
the question forward or
Kaustubh I see is already also pointing out
Perhaps Kaustubh first, just those
continuing with what he was talking
about some use cases that could arise we
could can we discuss that I mean I see
wearables coming into insurance before
the coming to Diagnostics mass
diagnostics because it turns todays
faces problems of determining you know
they operate on a fixed premium kind of
the basis of their risk will actually
not be the same for two different
patients are in for example there are
two patients are not patients to
individuals who want to buy insurance
policy of the same value one of them
happens to be the same age the insurance
company administers you know the usual
diagnostic tests the blood test and the
ecg stress test all that imagine what them
haven't seen battery doesn't on that
said day so the insurance premium is
fixed to be the same for both guys
tomorrow onwards say the person a is
very compliant with therapy but
personal B is not compliant therapy his
sugar levels go up and down where as
person A
II was compliant sugar levels another
and parameters we made within the back
now is it a fair model that an
insurance company charges the same
premium for both the guys obviously not
today
it operates like this now imagine a
scenario where
the insurance policy is sold with
available which actually tracks the
parameters continuously feed the data to
the insurance
company's server and there is an
algorithm which actually monitor picture
where which counter changes the premium
12 months depending on the complex so so
I I mean that's it reduces the risk of
the insurance company
it gives an incentive for the guy
who's complying properly
yeah and it also gives a wake-up call
for the guy who's not complying so it's
complete win-win situation so i see
compliance based the insurance premium
coming in and that's the kind of
business model which will have to be
tweaked a little in other spaces of healthcare as
well that's that's what I see
things heading
most definitely...in fact it's insteresting you mention
this because this is actually a
recurring  concept and
model also in terms of diabetes and
NCDs very often in non-communicable
diseases and chronic diseases i believe
the the model actually currently does
work also in Africa surprisingly it was
supported by the Clinton
Foundation as well initially the
insurance insured individuals on the
basis of how where they control their
diabetes for the time they haven't been
using variables but adding the variables
aspect to this equation could really
greatly modify the way we are handling
and dealing with health care but taking
an emerging economies as all of you
already mentioned where there's no
healthcare or centralized system
necessarily to help support the
individual a lot of it is privately
taken care of Sudha is there anything you'd
like to add to that question as well
well quickly and I think to ...
...
Sudha can you unmute your
mic I think you're on mute
hello yes yeah yes yeah we can hear me
yes Kaustubh just to comment on
your model what a it's impossible for
something that isn't monetary have this
be a lot of concern on can you hear me i see a
Kaustubh can't here me...am I audible going up and down
ok so Kaustubh
commenting on your proposed model
treating the insurance based on
compliance or behavioral aspects of an
individual and there's been a certain
what would I say lack of acceptance or a
certain concern in the genetics space one
were to have a mutation that predisposes
one to a certain disorder say at the age of 50
will they start a charging premium and I'm 20 years
old because is that fair to do
that's a question that is being asked
across and something will have to evolve
as you know social and ethical including
those aspects into the model as well infact
predictive test has those
concerns as well especially contexts of
india where it could lead to certain
kind of misuse
where'd you know the context of a person
in terms of what we have and what could
they could pass on to the next
generation
so if all of these tests coming to the
same and it would be
challenging doing this all of these
issues that's really interesting sudha
but then Sudha if I might ask
area but i have to wonder that genetics
is a large probably the first question
is an underlying important underlying
environment diet & N number of other things will
play a role but genetics can determine
the great deal so
how do we overcome this issue without stepping
on ethics
that you yeah what I'm trying to say
suppose that when we look at the genetic
context of both medicine it is an
important underlying aspect when we look
at personalizing medicine and at any
given time like you really pointed out
genetics can be a very important aspect
for ethics as well for breach of ethics
in many cases so
how do you envisage we can ever
implement something like this is
medicine in a country like India if
genetics is going to be an ongoing a
point of debate or mean I I'm some
courses there's no one wants to do it
but where do you think is one way of 1.1
way around it potentially so I last part
of your question but I'm like we come
into you is like two aspects to genetic
testing one he is and diagnostics which
is after the disease is manifested
itself and why they have cancer or you
have genetic disorder were trying to
get precise diagnostics for the patient
management there's another space which
is our predictive testing so if I know
my family member has been affected by
cancer risk for getting it and if I do
then what is the insurance i may find a
CAD feel mutation that quote you know I
might end up with cancer 20 years from
now so they're two different things and
treatment for slice therapies are
different wrong predictive tests so what
I was referring to is you know how do we
handle the outcomes of the predictive
test and with respect to insurance and
that is still a question open i think
adding and speak for questions with
questions
well large federal regulations are I'm
to imagine that you are right i think a
great deal more impetus needs to go into
into diagnostic genetic testing as
opposed to predictive from the point of view of
changing models initially when it comes
to insurance as I think this is is
always going to be a sticking point
something of great skepticism when it
comes to dealing with private insurance
insurance in particular postal employees
of entries when you have these employee
Wellness systems in place these days
practically every urban young individual
these days is
taken care of through the employee
wellness packages. If genetic test was added
to this mix I think it could also lead to a lot of
confusion and problems potentially allow
that rather i should say just conflicts
possibly and but we have little idea at
least for all of you already believe
could be one we are not implementing
some of these new technologies and the
newer systems in interms of regulation
in terms of also a diagnosis and
better care for individuals I'm not
curious to ask is something that's
come up recently from Novartis
where they've published that a great deal more
of the low and medium income nations
likely to suffer something in the lines of
seven trillion US
dollars
worth of losses in healthcare as a
result of chronic NCDs
chronic non-communicable diseases
and to some extent we need to find out
whether the flaw is just in the aging
population and the increasing
organization but ultimately if this is a
problem that we are looking to face in
the near future and countries like India
Brazil which traditionally are young
countries looking to age and have more
health issues as they grow and my
question to you now is that how you if
you were given responsibility to take
care of or to arrange the healthcare
system of country like India or Brazil
and you had access to all continue
resources
what would your strategy would you be
looking to put together something like
socially supported a healthcare system
like the national health services of the
UK or would you focus entirely on the
private privately-funded ongoing systems
or with the integrative diagnostics as
you've already alluded to in some be
some of you have in your discussions
focusing more on preventive medicine as
opposed to include possibly in
predictive medicine as opposed to
reactive medicine services in the
context of your NCD's and lifestyle
lifestyle diseases primarily
if i might ask nick to begin with
please...probably one that we can
spend days on discussing but the i mean
i think even Sudha had mentioned this I
mean it to me
health care in general is about
opportunity and access so if anybody has
to have access to some form of education
or care and without the access the
Bennett's it's you know it's not gonna
help anyone so i think yeah it's really
and I'm an American having lived in
Sweden Switzerland a little bit in japan
so I've seen actually the healthcare in
these different countries and there's a
course always advantages and
disadvantages in both like kind of a
socialist type of healthcare systems
such as in sweden i am privately private
insurance companies like in Switzerland
in the US
uh I think usually I mean at least from
my perspective has to be a combination
probably in a course getting to the
children early it seems to be something
out it should be a focus i mean if we
don't educate and implement kind of a
process or thought process into the
children that could be more preventative
than trying to attack somebody is ready
40 50 60 years old so kind of focusing
on the younger population right using
types of media that this population uses
for education is really important i
think it's also once kind of one kind of
interesting thought is about rural
medicine vs cities because that's you
you know Indian other countries you guys
how you gonna scale is the system from
millions of people the billion people
that's also quite a challenge and I
think not only the scaling but the
access to that for rural people and I
think not to talk too much about Roche
but they had something called the
Transnet there they've been working with
a company called transnet now and this
was mostly in Africa but this was
essentially having trains that go around
two more rural communities and provide
healthcare whether it be education
screening diabetes prevention medicine
access to medicine and especially a
focus on screening and diabetes
prevention i think especially for rural
type of medicine this what it looks like
a very good place with the hospital on
tracks so a system that's a combination
of both private and government system
that focuses on early prevention with
with educating the children i think
these are at least some thoughts and
everyone has to think about how we scale
something that's done in the millions of
people to a billion of people that
that's going to be really challenge so
that's it all very excellent points
mobile medicines as you rghtly pointed out
have to exist also in india currently
when it comes to screening and improving
both I think chronic diseases like that
diseases
while one would have a predisposition
are more lifestyle diseases and outcome
all how we eat and live and in that
context things like where the builders
and devices will be very important in
managing this the masses kill and I
think even the much spoken about happens
for model which is being very successful
in media where you have primary health
care centers secondary industry and the
primary ones addressing the larger mass
of locally will be very very important
morning to continue implementing Indian
context to scale it up quickly and
effectively so although these approach
this will be important
i recently read all
the success or IBM Watson to be faster
than an experienced clinician in
diagnosing patients given clinical
parameters perhaps a few IBM Watson
india or address a few thousand patients
that i'm given that a ratio of
transportation is one of the lowest in
the world and so we would have to
compliment multiple approaches where there is scale and need
Interesting, Kaustubh
regarding private be a very high-level
toward in some incense is it needs a lot
of resolution a lot of in the thinking to
get it implemented I just like if i can
share the screen and try if not let's
talk about it is the screenshare you see
my screen
yeah so what I well as i mentioned
earlier that you know these three more
to kind of the available anymore
diagnostic services two variables etc
the u.s. more do that i talked about
that way we can collect a lot of data
and that link it with the other guard
system that is coming up in India big
time and that will form the data
pipeline for all the data meters which
really obviously owned by the government
on top of that will sit the algorithm
creators that will slice the data is the
data kind of artificial intelligence
kind of stuff which will obviously be
the private players involved
funding will be there
and the users of this data will be the
healthcare companies of this game from
the private private space so this is the
kind of for you know the kind of for
more than that I feel it's cool and
forth the business model for the
government is going to be monetizing
that data that is going to be the
currency today the way you know the
comic cells this telecom circles that is
they sell the area's similarly data
could be sword to visit care companies
which could buy out the data and use the
data for actually providing healthcare
services
let's that's the kind of thing that I
see coming up and we should be a kind of
you know are developing the that kind of
the model and this Jam Jam that is JM
what the government is planning john
Dunn other and mobile that platform
which should the government is promoting
very very much these days that could be
capitalized there once again i repeat
that data pipeline is owned by the
government or daughter to see the
algorithm creators that private people
and on top of that is the other
companies to do you got it and create as
an tlk those are private she looks so
that's so I remodeling I feel that will
evil invention time i doing in action
somewhere you would you say this
something that that's actually being
tried a different scale and stay or do
you think that there's any states that
ever taken one so friendly as well I
don't see that happening because
everybody is talking about that other
platform for financial inclusion but it
has a lot of potential for these kinds
of applications as well I'm sure the
11-part want to be there must be
challenges in implementing be a huge
country and getting everybody
moving in the same direction you been
seeing the last three weeks for this the
monetization why don't I think being
done but execution has execution
religious to come up it's gonna take a
long time but at a broad level I think
that's the morning that should be boiled
in the long run
yeah that's definitely interesting i can
I just go back to both the second and
make to have your comments and this is
well particularly because if you're
looking at the government must be having
access to the data pipeline and
monetizing it together with private
place a you and visit X being an issue
is this the sort of skin of course a lot
of these things to anonymize there's no
identifiable data but you do sense that
there might be issues around that is web
based on your experiences so far if I
might just ask nick piece I mean first
or should be latest first but that I'll
go first
I think Scandinavia is quite the is
quite a good example of this i think you
guys can look more into how the system
works in places like Sweden and in
Denmark where they have these kind of
longitudinal data bases and yeah it
could be of genetics it could be a
prevalence of disease i think this could
be a half not 100-percent familiar with
it but access to samples Weatherby CSF
samples or are you know following
disease a lot of twin registries I think
haven't earned of issues regarding you
know confidentiality in these types of
databases but most investigators you
have access to this data and you can try
to basically do some data mining off
these registries yeah they're usually be
itemized you don't know necessarily the
patient is but i think it's a good
example for people to look into
especially this a Scandinavian
longitudinal assessments and I think
they've had quite successful
publications and learning front from
this type of registry so in Scandinavia
most definitely thank you exit point so
that your comments on the same peace
process
so I'm 100 million that success all this
will depend also on improvements in
infrastructure in India also they're not
really a lot of this is going to be
data-intensive and it requires that this
connectivity to the last night that's
when it will be effective but it just
happens i think that's the best way to
move forward and these questions on
people concerns will remain but i think
the need of the hour is the think tank
that thanks to these problems ahead of
john I'm and comes up with structure the
gradual rather than something that's
dramatic because that's been typically
the outcomes are not great when there's
acceptance gradual acceptance of things
then it if you usually incorporate into
the structure very nice point with on
with ya in with dr. look about the
government seems to have graduated
already attended last 8-10 years of
course last mile problems are always
there and they will exist but as a long
time I think that's the large framework
that should be followed
let's that's my view ok I think we have
a very interesting that we have a very
interesting almost became part of the
general the bickering of scenes you tend
to be connectivity access education and
ultimately as supporting the government
and the protector and a hybrid format so
that's really interesting to hear from
all of you but of course we can't really
talk about these innovations without
first addressing or some levels of
pressing the potential pitfalls and this
traditionally understood that most
innovations will have five major gaps
when it comes to performance in
structure sustainability a regulation
and or in preference of the end
user so where do you think in your
experience of the market of the Indian
context of course but also generate
emerging markets where are we likely to
face some of the biggest challenges in
terms of these pitfalls and these gaps
if I might begin this question with
Sudha please so i guess in
generation
thank you the question here from your
voices breaking so i'm just reading
between the lines I would think the
primary have limited taking context
would be on infrastructure and much of
it has i think just be assured by the
private entities to overcome for many of
these things and ETA in fact it has also
be an opportunity for innovation in on
the other side where if there is no
access to some other ways on morning
that can be reaching the patient quickly
and without the need for big
infrastructure I think menu for example
there was this model where for trying to
work for tracking the contraction there
was very simple Divine's me get that
could go from village to village if a
mother's late did not have required the
patient reach the hospital for childhood
so when there is lack of infrastructure
it also book and innovation so which is
vital to win bad but i think we still
have a long ways people and
infrastructure and a second course on
the performance i'm a savior of the
Indian context
we've done very berry or on maximizing
returns from existing technologies
because of the knee itself created
providing services improving processes
and protocols and that's been a
significant advantage sustainability
will depend quite a bit on the
government
support on how this can be implemented
across and make sustainable regulations
not creatively context from healthcare
perspective at least in the agonistic
space we have a long ways to go
we don't have a mechanism like it is
there in the developed world and needs
to be worked upon so I think motivating
perspective I would put infrastructure
as were the biggest gaps in the Indian
context that's very interesting thank
you and your baby can you carry it like
have a question is would you like to
push but ok yeah i mean there's always
gaps five seems minimal so but the focus
on these i mean i think in terms of
performance it's always validation and
reproducibility so with any tests no
matter what it is
I mean how reproducible as these
outcomes and how reproducible is to
measure i think this is really under
under validated actually people do not
really look enough into the performance
I think even like what is it there knows
now that has major problems I mean so
it's a you know as accurate we need to
be accurate because anytime you go to
implement something such a large-scale a
you know it could be then a very big
waste of money if it's not as validate
and reproducible as everyone hopes that
the B it's a pseudo and others already
mentioned quite a lot about access and
no matter what it is it's always gonna
be again the scalability to and
providing access to the two people i
think is the main things of course it
also always comes down to cost and i
think is whatever it is whether it's a
diagnostic test or it's a drug
I mean it has to be a people have to be
all for it so governments have to be all
for today obviously the patient has to
be all for it and I think cost is always
a gap
cost of your comment space on this I I
agreement so that when she says about
infrastructure is going to be the
biggest challenger digital connectivity
is gonna be the biggest challenge but
what happens is because we have these
constraints a lot of innovators push
themselves hard and get over it
a great example is you-know-who which
bank would you believe in India has the
maximum internet penetration
normal names were come icici or make an
axis bank reported back but no it's is
bi-state Biophilia the important that we
call them but they have figured our
technology which doesn't feel smart
phones to access your internet banking
there a simple java enabled for the
basic nokia phones that use 10 years
back you can do internet banking using
the java enabled phone if you have an
SBA car so that's how people will omit
the robust and the hostile conditions in
emerging economies developing countries
push away the Laurel less cost also what
happens in the in the country like ours
is you know say a country which is
distributed over population or maybe 50
or 60 million you have an Indian
seven-step spreads over 500 600 million
so cost per capita also comes down so
it's about it's about taking that first
step
there's gonna be there's gonna be a lot
of peeling trouble but yes there has to
be dominant sustainable support all
through private enterprises will
obviously look at the long-term returns
and they will stick with it so it's it's
it's it's a it's I don't see it's a
cat-and-mouse game it's it's a it's it's
it's going to take time but yes it is
going to take time but
yeah i mean that that's my view I can be
a very unanimous idea around the
potential gaps it seems that the
actually and one working mom I feel my
personal view is the Indian Supreme
Court is becoming a little too active in
terms of you know not letting some
things getting legislated and things
like that for example again coming back
to this other a identification the
government the previous government as
well as this government has been very
keen that every single Indian gets
another card and it kind of becomes
complicity in the long run I think this
activism of the Supreme Court is
somewhere hampering this UID attempt of
the government that's that's my view so
what activism from the judiciary also is
not good for penetration of you are
developed and were they call it isn't so
as a quick person and thank you for that
comment as well and would again broadly
speaking just a moment to think so
there's a comment
yes just to get the only country that is
more or less than answers china and it's
a communist country so they can just
implement laws that end it happen
democracy like this 1.6 billion views of
everything mobile i think we are on the
right part of thing somewhere between
the initiatives of digital India and the
very many attempts also about the
government with the other guard what
else everything else in between
plus the ingenuity of the upcoming
entrepreneurs and startups and
disruptive technologies that are
currently driving in india i think that
there might be hope that we have gotten
our hands hopefully a very novel new
model to look into in the coming years
and we are actually already running all
the time but we have one question from
here which I find rather interesting i'd
love to have all three of you attended
or if one of you in particular would
like to address this we have a question
from dr. Sean ground and
in poverty in dundee would like to know
where what are the implications possibly
of contraceptives and birth control in
countries emerging economies and how
will that pan out of play out
potentially in healthcare modeling in
the future and if any takers do we have
any of you would you like to address
that question do you realize and the
question was the question was should
healthcare or should healthcare also
account for birth control and for
contraception in emerging economies in
order to better control for certain
health conditions
ok anybody wanted to take it
yeah I think Norma higher educational
levels and awareness levels is going to
take care of that
ah ah we're not a communist country so
we can't enforce the conception a single
giant policy the way China can do we
have to be at a much more liberal
country and that it has to be technical
education but it's only accent okay
and on that note I think I'd just like
to thank all of the speakers today then
for your time and some very interesting
interesting insight so I think we have a
lot to take from this in order to move
forwards and and you out of the parts in
the various fields that we working so
once again thank you all for joining us
we'll be in touch again very soon
thank you thank you